there's been a lot of hype around arm
laptops in the past year because it
basically gives you a less expensive
laptop that's thinner lighter and
packing more battery life than a
traditional laptop and that's exactly
what you get with Samsung's Galaxy Book
S which we believe is the best arm
laptop available right now it's packing
a seven nanometer mobile ARM chip which
is not only powerful but super efficient
so it doesn't require loud fans to keep
it cool which is one of my personal
favorite things about this laptop you
also get incredibly good battery life
rated up to 25 hours running Windows 10
now if you've seen our review of the
galaxy Book s you'll know that there are
definitely some issues with it
mainly software support and
optimizations so after using this for a
couple of days we got to thinking what
if it makes more sense to simply skip
out on this arm laptop and just go for
Apple's iPad pro instead now it's
obviously a tablet that doesn't run
desktop software but it's become more
and more like an actual laptop in the
past year thanks to tons of software
improvements and new apps now if you
want to learn more about that be sure to
check out our iPad pro in 20/20 review
after this video so to make our iPad pro
comparable to the galaxy book s we have
to make sure it's a 256 gigabyte model
with LTE connectivity since that's what
you get with the Samsung we also have to
get a keyboard case in the bridge pro
case for 100 to $150 on Amazon is the
best out there however it doesn't pack a
trackpad which is an exclusive feature
that's coming to the Bridge Pro Plus
which is shipping next month together
with a regular bridge pro keyboard it
brings the price of the iPad pro to
around 1150 to $1,200 a couple hundred
more than the book S and that's what the
11 inch iPad pro model not the larger 12
point 9 inch which is more expensive and
is a better fit as a laptop replacement
another downside of the iPad is that you
don't get true cursor support like you
do with the arm laptop now there are
rumors that Apple is working on a smart
keyboard with the built-in trackpad
which shows that there's a chance Apple
will be adding cursor support but
there's no guarantees
to the comparison the book s is quite a
bit thinner and lighter compared to the
iPad pro with its keyboard case but the
iPad has a much smaller footprint thanks
to the 11 in size Samsung did an
excellent job with their hinge being
easy to open but sturdy as well the
hinge on the bridge keyboard isn't as
easy to open but it seems like it's even
more sturdy and it has the added benefit
of laying flat on a table looking at
them side by side the display on the
Samsung is obviously much larger but
since its using a 16 by 9 aspect ratio
you only get a bit more vertical space
than on the iPad which is surprising and
you can obviously remove the keyboard if
you want to use the iPad like a tablet
for even more vertical screen space
since the keyboard case has to match the
11 inch size of the iPad the keys are a
bit scrunched together so it's not as
comfortable to type on compared to the
Galaxy which has a full-size keyboard
with keys that feel better than on the
bridge keyboard they feel really nice
and tactile just what you'd expect from
a laptop and of course the trackpad on
the book S is the star of the show with
true cursor support with Windows 10 it's
definitely not as good as a MacBook
trackpad but it's actually decent
compared to other Windows laptops now
comparing the displays the iPad pros
display is quite a bit brighter and it's
very color accurate with dcpip three
wide color gamut the major downside of
the galaxy book s is that the screen is
very reflective alongside the lower
brightness so it's definitely hard to
see the display when you're in a bright
room or outside the Samsung's display is
a touchscreen but it doesn't work nearly
as well as the iPad pro which features
120 Hertz
Pro motion technology so it's super
smooth and fluid and this also means
that the Apple pencil gets incredibly
low amounts of latency so the drawing
and note-taking experience is excellent
a huge benefit is that the speakers are
really nice and loud on the galaxy book
S sounding quite a bit louder than on
the iPad pro however the quality itself
was a bit dull and muted especially in
the highs compared to the iPad
[Music]
[Music]
the front-facing camera for skyping or
using FaceTime is definitely quite a bit
better on the iPad here's a comparison
so you can see it for yourself this is a
front-facing video in microphone quality
tests on the 2018 iPad pro this is a
video in microphone quality test of the
front-facing camera on the Galaxy book s
in terms of the ports the iPad pro
features just one USB C port which can
be used to hook up to external storage
drives and hubs that give you extra
ports the Galaxy book ass actually comes
with two of them which makes a huge
difference it also comes with a
headphone jack which is missing on the
iPad pro so you're definitely getting
much better ports on the Samsung while
both of these devices have a matching
256 gigs of storage you can get up to
one terabyte on the iPad pro if you're
willing to pay a couple hundred bucks
more
however the Samsung comes with a micro
SD card slot allowing you to get an
extra one terabyte of storage at a much
lower price file management was
definitely better on the Samsung
compared to Apple's files app which just
doesn't have as much functionality but
it's been much improved with iPad OS
even though the battery on the galaxy
book S is only around 40% larger than
the battery on the iPad pro it's rated
for 25 hours of battery life compared to
around 10 on the iPad pro now in the
real world we definitely didn't see that
much battery life we experienced around
16 to 20 on the galaxy book s depending
on what you're doing which is definitely
better than the six to eight hours we
saw on this iPad pro one thing we did
notice is that the standby battery life
was worse on the Samsung draining more
battery life while not in use compared
to the iPad pro now before we talk about
software differences I want to get into
performance when looking at standard
benchmarks like Geekbench 5 CPU tests
the iPad pro is getting around two times
more multi-core performance which is
surprising because it's around a year
and a half old now we usually run the
graphics test in Geekbench but it
doesn't work on arm laptops so we have
to skip that test we instead found a
graphics browser test called motion mark
version one point
one and here the galaxy book asks scored
one hundred and two points compared to
694 on the iPad pro which is a massive
difference we also tested the
speedometer 2.0 browser benchmark which
shows us general browser performance for
basically anything on the web in this
test the galaxy scored fifty nine point
three points compared to a hundred and
thirty seven on the iPad pro so you're
definitely getting a much better web
browsing experience on the iPad now we
actually ran this test on three
different browsers on the Samsung we ran
Firefox the new Microsoft edge and
Google Chrome and the new edge scored
the best with that fifty nine point
three score we achieved since it's the
most optimized for ARM chips now putting
benchmarks aside we decided to compare
the real world performance between the
two we first played asphalt nine and on
the iPad pro it runs incredibly well
perfectly smooth at 60 frames per second
the galaxy book asks on the other hand
was horribly choppy the FPS was so low
that it was basically unplayable we also
downloaded Photoshop on both of these
devices and even with eight gigabytes of
RAM on the book s compared to four on
the iPad pro the experience was much
more smooth on the iPad for example the
Spot Healing Brush was much more
responsive and quicker on the iPad then
on the bagasse now while the Samsung
does get Windows 10 it doesn't support
64-bit apps which are basically most of
them including the most powerful apps so
you're very limited in terms of the apps
you can use another downside is that
since it runs Windows 10 and not Android
you don't get access to any mobile apps
either on the iPad pro you obviously
don't get any desktop programs but you
get access to a massive library of iOS
apps which are all very optimized a lot
of them have also been updated to use
more and more of the iPad pros power so
they all work very well
this means that gaming is going to be
many many times better on the iPad then
on the book s but of course you don't
get a cursor in real full-size desktop
apps like the quickbooks online app for
business owners on the other hand the
ipad
have its own highly optimized app for
that so it comes down to the final
question is it worth buying an arm
laptop right now when you can just buy
an iPad pro honestly I still think it's
a bit too early for arm laptops since a
lot of the desktop apps haven't been
updated for 32-bit or optimized forearm
chips you just don't get the same
software support compared to how many
apps you can get right now on the iPad
and since iPad OS was such an excellent
update the iPad pro actually functions
well as a laptop replacement so we would
honestly choose that instead of the
galaxy book s now we are excited for
Apple to switch their Mac books to arm
because first of all those Mac books
will have access to all of the great iOS
apps alongside desktop apps something
that you just can't get on the galaxy
book s an Apple has been working very
hard to make it easier for developers to
turn their 64-bit apps into 32-bit so
the transition to arm will be quite a
bit easier and quicker in terms of
software but for now the iPad pro is an
excellent choice but at a slightly
higher price since you'll also have to
buy the keyboard case as well so
whichever one you choose we'll have
links down in the description below if
you enjoy this video check out those two
videos right over there and click the
circle about to subscribe thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]